bonjour a dit la double razeq merci
d'être avec nous cet après midi sur rt
france alors on l'a dit 80 auxiliaires
de l'armée françaises attendent toujours
un visa est ce que vous avez bon espoir
quant à leur venue prochaine en france
un grand merci de m'avoir donné cette
opportunité est temps de parler
concernant la situation des dentiers
auxiliaires de l'armée française en
afghanistan comme de nos jours la
situation sécuritaire en afghanistan se
dégrade de jour en jour surtout pour des
anciens auxiliaires de l'armée française
en afghanistan et il y à 80 auxiliaires
qui ont déjà collaboré l'armée française
est actuellement ils sont une sous les
menaces des talibans et leurs
sympathisants ils attendent toujours
d'être évacué par l'état français il ya
déjà une bonne nouvelle pour le
président de maquereaux et lan vient
d'annoncer qu'ils vont donner le visa
pour tous les ressortissants et
et des gens qui ont travaillé pour la
pour la france
florence parly la ministre des armées a
aussi assuré 1 que la france n'oublie
ray pas les auxiliaires les interprètes
et tous ceux qui ont travaillé
pour pour la france est ce que est ce
que justement vous avez bon espoir de
voir vos compatriotes venir en france le
plus rapidement possible
bien sûr j'ai de bons espoirs qu'un jour
tous mes collègues qui ont déjà
collaboré l'armée française seraient
évacués de l'afghanistan surtout depuis
que les talibans ils ont leur prix le
pouvoir dans toutes les provinces de la
can i stand et elles ont repris les
contrôles de tous les districts de
kaboul a pourtant le porte parole des
taliban les avait annoncé une amnistie
pour tout le monde pour les
fonctionnaires du gouvernement pour les
anciens ou des lèvres l'armée française
des forces d'autant mais normalement on
avoue qu'ils n'ont pas tourné tout nous
notre promesse il ya une semaine après
cette annonce mans des zones assassiné
un de notre collègue et sa colère de
bâtir des deux semaines après de cet
arrondissement ils ont décapité après
d'américains c'est pour ça qu
actuellement tous les collègues qu'ils
attendent d'être évacués
ils sont enfermés chez eux les attendent
toujours un point de contact de la part
de l'ambassade de france à kaboul
vous parliez à l'instant de vos anciens
collègues toujours sur place est-ce que
vous en avez eu certains au téléphone
est ce que vous en avez contacté
certains cas quel est leur état d'esprit
aujourd'hui sont-ils confiant quant à
l'avenir à venir justement sur sur le
sol français
bien sûr depuis la location de président
les mains de mary mc ren ils ont
toujours le bon espoir de mettre à
relocaliser par l'état l'état français
est actuellement il a tenté sont tous
optimistes d'être évacué de kaboul vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure les talibans
avaient assuré que les interprètes et
les auxiliaires n'était pas forcément en
danger vous nous avez dit que c'était
finalement le le contraire avec ce qui
s'est passé les talibans qui affirment
avoir changé est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous croyez
selon moi les talibans ils n'ont pas
changé d'avis c'est pareil si on peut
comme l'année 98
ils ont imposé des restrictions aux
femmes aux journalistes il a
certainement filles qui sont
actuellement privés de la scolarité ils
sont et ils n'ont pas ou ne sont pas
autorisés d'aller à l'université comme
on avoue que certaines filles ne sont
pas autorisés d'aller à l'université des
rates
merci kaboul merci beaucoup d abdul
razaq d'avoir été avec nous cet après
midi sur rt frange rappelle avec vous
êtes président de l'association des
anciens auxiliaires de l'armée française
merci beaucoup